would any rational man join a church that women held
all the priest of leadership positions
including prophet apostles
state presidents and bishops
god was a woman and any mention of father in heaven was basically prohibited
only women were allowed to speak for god
under no circumstance could a man hold a position of authority over a woman
only women could perform church ordinances
pass the sacrament
perform baptisms
bless their own children in the temple
women covenanted to obey their mother in heaven but the men
they covenanted to obey their wives
the fundamental narrative upon which the entire religion were based
had a man obeying Satan to eat the forbidden fruit
which would explain why men are subservient to women
men were told time and time again in general conference
from all their female leaders
that their main purpose was to be submissive to their wives
at age 12 the girls got the priesthood
with subsequent advancement during their teen years
but the boys got nothing but a manhood medallion
the only men's group in the church was called the Relief Society
which was really run by women apostles who made all the real decisions
women frequently gave men priested blessings of council
pretending to speak in the name of Heavenly Mother
commanding them to obey their wives and to be faithful
most precious thing a man could do was give his wife his virginity
men who lost their virginity before marriage were called used cars or chewed gum
or licked cupcakes
single
men were told that they could only be exalted if their wives called upon them
for exaltation
in an ex life
a woman could have as many husbands as she wanted
while her husband could have only her
the men are expected to take many classes on how to change toilet floppers
sharpen lawn mower blades
or fixed fences while the women meet to discuss leadership doctrine
a man who has a huge business empire and a great education
is only allowed to be in charge of other men or children
never women in the church
he wonders what his wife's temple name might be
she knows his
the church had a history of treating men like mindless property
the church founder
a woman had over 30 husbands
some of them were prepubescent boys she emotionally blackmailed into secret sex
some were happily married men
and she told them to marry her in order to save their family
the church's scriptures contain a revelation by the church's founder
a woman that has Heavenly Mother
saying she gives the virgin men to the founder
and her husband must accept it or suffer eternal destruction in damnation
The Book of Mormon only has four pathetic references to men when